So many people think that polygamy means
a man having more than one wife. No.
Polygamy means a person having more than
one spouse. It's of two types.
One is polygeni when a man has more than
one wife and the other is polyandry
where a woman has more than one husband.
So Islam prohibits polyandry
but permits limited polygeny. So many
people think that polygamy means a man
having more than one wife. No. Polygamy
means a person having more than one
spouse. It's of two types.
One is polygeni when a man has more than
one wife and the other is polyandry
where a woman has more than one husband.
So Islam prohibits polyandry
but permits limited polygeny.
Before I give the answer,
why does Islam permit a man to have more
than one wife?
Let me tell you that Quran is the only
religious book on the face of the earth.
It is the only scripture on the face of
the earth which tells you marry only
one. There is no other religious book.
Whether it be the Bible, whether it be
the Veda, whether it be the opanishad,
whether it be Ramayan, whether it be
Mahabharat, whether it be Bhagat Gita,
whether it be Dhapat, whether it be Zed
Avesa,
whether
it be any other scripture, no scripture
except the Quran tells you marry only
one.
If you read the scriptures of the other
religions besides Islam, there is no way
mentioned you should marry only one. Now
most of the people think that all the
other religions say marry one. They have
not read the scripture. It's a
misconception. In fact,
if
you read the Hindu scriptures, it talks
about many great personalities in
Hinduism.
Like if you read Raman the father of
Shri Ram king Dashrat he had more than
one wife.
If you read Mahabharat Sri Krishna, how
many wives he had? 4 10,000
16,18
wives. How many?
wives. Now when I'm giving 16,18
exact figure, it's not approximate. It's
mentioned in the scriptures.
And Radha
was not one of the wives.
Though he had 16,8
yet he had a woman by the name of Radha
who was not the wife. I don't want to
continue what the scripture says.
So in Hinduism you can marry as many as
you wish.
Even in Christianity there is no
restriction.
You can marry as many as you wish.
It is only later on
that the church a few centuries ago put
a restriction that a Christian man
should marry only one. But there is no
statement anywhere in the Bible where it
says you should marry only one woman. No
way. No limit. You can marry 10, 20, 30,
40, 50, no problem. 100, no problem. If
you read the Bible,
Abraham peace be upon him had
three wives.
Solomon peace be upon him had 700 wives.
So no restriction as many as you want.
IT IS THE CHURCH WHICH A FEW centuries
ago put a restriction that Christian
should have only one. Similarly in
Hinduism you can marry as many as you
wish.
India Indian government put a
restriction in 1954
in Hindu marriage act that Hindus should
marry only one. The scripture has no
limit. You can marry four 5 10 100,000
no problem. When she Christian can have
16,18
who can stop you to have thousand wives.
It is the Indian law
not God. In 1954
passed
a rule Hindu marriage act that Hindus
should marry only one otherwise even
Jews. And Jews they can marry as many as
they wish. It was only when Rabbi
Genshim Ben Yehuda who lived from 1960
to 130 CE
he passed
a law that Jews should only marry one.
But yet the Jews living in Muslim
communities the sephratic Jews living in
the Muslim communities Muslim
communities yet they continued having
more than one wife. It was only 1950
when the chief rabbi of Israel put a ban
that Jews cannot marry more than one
woman.